it's been one year I'm still mad at you
I still get this anger that built in my
chest and then I have to think about
something else I want to just be filled
with love and memories and sweetness but
maybe the truth is that this anger is
part of me now I think of all the little
times as mad at you before one night we
were supposed to go out and all of her
friends bailed I assumed we would just
go out ourselves you assumed I would
know that when they cancelled you would
want to stay in I was mad when you
randomly became very neat and orderly
you were my partner and messiness and
and suddenly it was two on one I was mad
when we got you a birthday cake and you
didn't need any of it because you were
picky about sweets
I was mad every time I saw you flirting
up a storm and not make a move so many
of our female friends were into you and
I was mad you could never see it but I
wasn't really mad at any of those things
now I know what it is to really be mad
[Music]
I'm mad now because I can't give you
[ __ ] for any of your weird habits
anymore I'm mad now because I have to be
the sole keeper of so many memories I'm
mad because our friends will never
forget that anxious day-and-a-half I'm
mad that after living with you for two
years this is how I got to know your
family I'm mad for all the time we all
spend analyzing everything you ever said
to us I'm mad because every time I see
my best friend we feel a hole where you
should be I'm mad now because I can't
tell you that an uber full of drunk
people all the way in India we're
jamming out to your mixtape I'm mad now
because every time that something or
someone that we used to laugh at pops up
on my facebook I have nobody to text
into
and Maddie won't be in my wedding
pictures mad that traffic cones bamboo
KitKat bars
oranges and punch at parties I'll make
me sad now I met that you make me sad
now I'm mad you never told me
I'm Matt it wasn't obvious to you how
much I would have wanted to fight this
with you and Matt I'll never know what
you were going through I'm mad that
maybe I never knew you I'm mad that I
can't stop feeling mad
but maybe love is every emotion all
wrapped into one if love can make you
happy and sad and love can make you mad
too I'm mad at you because I love you
and I really [ __ ] miss you I hope
that one day that love is wistful and
nostalgic right now manifest this anger
[Music]
you